let's start first just with give me a
sentiment check on uh bitcoin the market
uh macro et cetera like how you feeling
right now yeah i don't think we've
talked since uh bitcoin uh nuked on on
the weekend uh what was it two weeks ago
um that was fun got some liquidations
some volatile price action after some
consolidation um i'm feeling good i
think a lot of a lot of people were
expecting bitcoin to go parabolic
including myself i'm on the record for
saying that um but i don't think the
structure of
i guess this bull market or what
bitcoin's going to do in the coming
coming months and years has has really
changed at all it's just you know what
bitcoin does kind of takes the path of
the next pain all right let's look
backwards before we kind of look at
where we are right now walk us through
kind of your understanding of we
absolutely busted through all-time highs
went to 69 000. nice and then we've
drawn down into the 40s uh what's
driving a lot of that is that macro
shock is that just pure liquidations
market got too frothy too much
derivative stuff like what's really
driving that draw down
yeah i mean so a lot of it is that you
know derivatives or you know traders
speculators were out of position so um
you have the underlying spot demand for
bitcoin you have people like yourself
like you know
the listeners of this show um people
going out and just buying bitcoin on
cash up or strike or coinbase or
whatever it is they're exchanging fiat
for dollars and then there's kind of
speculators that can use bitcoin they
can use other cryptos they can use
stable coins and they can basically on
margin or with leverage uh bet on the
price of bitcoin to go up and if you see
too many people uh kind of offsides
doing that at once um essentially like
you know when the price broke 69 000 or
briefly tapped it there a lot of the
market was levering up and so so you
kind of see even traders that are
bullish on bitcoin uh you know whales
will with a lot of capital uh who are
long-term extremely bullish on the asset
will you know try to try to get those
and successfully did get those those
traders liquidated you know make them
force sellers and so that's kind of what
a lot of this price action is recently i
think some of it has to do with a little
bit of macro uncertainty oh you know the
fed is is starting to taper i included
some charts about uh you know euro
dollar futures and the dixie which we
can talk about in a minute but i think
there is some sort of you know risk off
sentiment in markets we saw the vix
which is the volatility index for the s
p spike uh right before those that
massive weekend liquidation a couple
weeks back um hit hit i think 35 which
was the highest it had since since
january of this year so there was more
of just a risk-off element you know it
wasn't just bitcoin
but i think you know that's that's
getting priced in and has been getting
pricing for the last week or two
all right let's talk about now we've got
a bitcoin realized price and uh
currently the market cap sits at about
892 billion which news flash is below a
trillion for those keeping track at home
uh but the realized cap's only 461
billion tell us kind of what you think
this is showing us
yeah so i i kind of color coordinated
this chart over time and you can kind of
see realized price it's like almost like
a non-volatile bitcoin chart right it's
it's not as as you know
much of a boom and bust and more just
kind of a steady uptrend with these
these big re-evaluations uh every you
know highlighted in green and so so the
green is is basically a bull market and
that's when the realized price this
orange uh line is is curving up where
it's going parabolic and so realized
realize cap a realized price uh realized
cap is basically the aggregate
of every utxo or every bitcoin
technically on the network when it was
last moved so um that's kind of i would
i like to call this like almost not an
intrinsic value like maybe a subjective
value of bitcoin the network and we can
see this with full transparency and so
basically realized cap of the realized
price has been
somewhat of a bear market floor um
you've seen it cross under that a few
times throughout history and that's been
generational buying opportunities but i
think realized cap realized price is
like the most pure form of kind of
quantifying the monetization process of
bitcoin and so right now we're kind of
in this consolidation phase where
realize cap is appreciating to the tune
of about 700 million since the bottom of
the market in may in june and so you
know we're still increasing but we're
not we're not seeing the tens of
billions hundreds of billions of dollars
of inflows into the market which would
you know need need the price which would
need to see the price to go parabolic
okay and then what about taking this
exact same realized market
capitalization but doing the 14-day
moving average uh you've got these
really fancy arrows that you drew on
here what was this showing us
yeah it's just the same charges zoomed
in a little bit you can kind of see
what's what's uh happening in closer
view and so um i put the 14 day moving
average just to kind of smooth out some
of the volatility but what you see is
the slope of that realized cap or that
realized price increase is kind of
showing these market phases so um the
the reason that this that realized price
or realized cap
goes kind of vertical is two reasons
this one old coins are selling but it's
really that's that's because of the
first reason which is there's so much
capital there's so much uh you know new
money flooding into this market flooding
into this asset class and so you get a
combination of those two you get a
basically a green bull market you see
this you know realize price appreciate
by maybe an order of magnitude uh or two
and so um we're not in that kind of
green phase yet where we're seeing these
massive capital inflows but i think the
catalyst is is what's to come in
potentially 2022 uh or later but um and
that's kind of the macro uncertainty in
the macro situation that we're we're
seeing play out in real time
okay before we move on to the next round
i want to go back to the zoomed out
version the first chart that we showed
and again i'm not a genius but i can
read colors and every time i see yellow
it's followed by green i never see
yellow then red is that a rule is there
any like a way to else to read into this
or do you always get green after yellow
yeah i mean that's historically that's
what we've seen with the red means
essentially that there's there's on
chain losses there's realized losses so
a coin's acquired in 2017 for 20k on
chain and you can see this with full
transparency in the bitcoin utxo set
anybody can can spin up a full node
download the entire history of the
network and see this happening and that
coin later moves for say three thousand
dollars in 2019 that's a that's a
realized loss there was a 17 000
uh loss on chain you can if it was one
bitcoin you know this is just an example
um and so when you see basically like
say at the top of the market in 2017 to
the bottom of the bear market the
realized cap decreased by like one of
the realized price decreased by like a
thousand dollars and so so basically the
whole time that whole 80 drawdown it was
just coins transferring hands and a lot
of top buyers were transferring those
weekends or transferring to strong
convicted hodlers and so yeah i think i
think you know the yellow is always
followed by the green because um i i
labeled it accumulation slash parabola
and that's just kind of what you see is
that you know just steady increase
that's that plateaus or you know a
slight uptrend that's that's kind of the
you know mark of a of accumulation trend
and then a following accumulation that's
usually when bitcoin goes parabolic but
you know history rhymes but you know
doesn't really let's see what happens
all right let's get to our third chart
here we've got the bitcoin market value
to realize value ratio explain what this
is before you tell us what this chart's
showing it's just for the people that
forgot
yeah so i'm just basically taking the
first couple shots we showed and we're
just running a ratio of that so when
realized when the when the price goes
far above the realized price uh you can
see basically like the past bubbles in
the bitcoin market uh you see this ratio
really overextend to the upside and so
that's kind of you know even if you're
super bullish long term on bitcoin uh
the lower this goes the more attractive
it is to buy on a relative basis and so
you kind of see uh at every top of the
bull market this this ratio really
overextends the price has been up at the
margin and not a lot of activity is
happening on chain in the sense that not
a lot of coins are moving and so any new
buyer has to come in and really has to
push up this price on the margin
and then there's this massive kind of
distribution and and re-accumulation and
that's when this ratio kind of bottoms
and so i'm not saying we're going to go
to this below the green line which means
that price would go below the realized
price which is currently 25k
but that's that's kind of the the
ultimate floor and we see that floor
kind of rising every single day you see
these these kind of reevaluation bubbles
happen with bitcoin it doesn't trade in
linear fashion and so the market value
to realize value ratio is i think is one
of the best tools to kind of evaluate
this process happening in real time
and you know despite all the volatility
essentially you're just seeing this this
asset accrue value in real time with
full transparency
if bitcoin went to 25 000 i'd sell this
table this computer this microphone
everything you all ain't gonna hear from
me i'll be backing up the truck i i hope
that happens like likewise yeah
we'll be doing uh videos off our phones
and sitting on the floor together it'll
be perfect uh all right you also uh have
two charts here which i don't think
we've covered before the first one is uh
december 2022 euro dollar futures and i
know most people don't know what this is
so explain what we're looking at here
why you think this is important
yeah so the euro dollar market your euro
dollar futures um it's essentially the
offshore dollar market and what this is
showing is essentially it's it's a
futures market uh betting
essentially betting on on the fed funds
rate right so this is december 2022 and
um a euro dollar market at 100 would
mean that the fed funds rate is at zero
zero zero basis points and so if the
euro dollar futures market is at 99 what
that's saying is that
basically traders the consensus right
now in the market is that the fed is
going to hike three times in 2022 from
25 basis points to 100 basis points and
so um this is something that i think um
you know even even just 100 basis points
one percent fed funds rate it's pretty
laughably low with inflation at six
seven percent uh but you know i think
there is some cost for concern
potentially um with how risk risk assets
such as equities and a lot of just you
know really everything in the everything
bubble is priced off these laughably
negative real yields and so if the fed
hikes three times i think there
potentially could be some sort of
maybe risk off event or some sort of
volatility and it's just one of the
things that you know that we're keeping
an eye on and heading into 2022. okay
then we've got the us dollar currency
index the dxy uh why is this important
yeah so it's kind of interrelated uh
with the fed's fund rate but the you
know everybody likes to talk about
including myself about inflation in the
us cpi maybe you know ppi that the
producers index coming in at 10
year-over-year um but you know what's
what's really important in terms of uh
the global financial system is the
dollar relative to other fiat currencies
um because you know us in the us uh you
know domestically uh we're worried about
what things cost uh in dollar terms and
when that's rising we're saying
inflation inflation is bad uh but a lot
of foreigners um you know there's a lot
of foreign denominated or us denominated
debt out there held by foreigners and so
when the dollar is strengthening
relative to their currencies to their
local currencies whether it's the euro
the yen the rent the renvy and china um
you know these foreigners have to sell
dog denominated assets and bitcoin is
you know is is the denominator in
bitcoin is the dollar and so say in
march of 2020 what do you see the dixie
do uh you see that that's super spike
and that's basically the reason every
single asset on the planet sold off in a
huge way you can think of it as the
dollar was getting bid in that scenario
and so
the dollar strengthened throughout 2021
relative to other fiats is notable um
and if this trend continues you can kind
of expect some some downwards uh
pressure on risk assets bitcoin included
got it and then when you start to look
at uh this next chart that we have here
this is the historically the historical
daily transfer volume i have no clue
what this means so you're gonna have to
educate me along with everybody else why
what is this showing us
yeah so this these next two charts here
uh a little bit different than our kind
of usual usual talk but i've seen a lot
of uh chatter recently especially with
um ethereum and bitcoin and the btc
chart um kind of nearing breakout levels
um and so uh i will talk about that in a
second but what this is showing is the
historical daily transfer volume of the
bitcoin network and i apply just a two
week moving average to it uh and then i
the the orange line of what it's showing
is
what is the transfer volume and this is
change adjusted transfer volume for
those that are a little more technical
um but you know disregard that but this
is showing the orange line is showing
how much
uh volume is being transferred on chain
for every one dollar in fees and so what
we essentially see is over the last
decade
from 2011 i just i just chose a date on
the chart uh to today um despite
bitcoin's daily transfer volume uh going
from 100 000
to 50 billion uh the settlement
efficiency of the bitcoin network has
stayed the same and so and so it's
pretty pretty remarkable to see that
despite this thing
being adopted by millions tens of
millions hundreds of millions of people
um and the on-chain transaction volume
and dollar terms increasing by orders of
magnitude the settlement efficiency of
the network uh has actually um depending
on where you're plotting it against has
actually increased um and so for anyone
that's saying bitcoin is inefficient or
slow or can't scale uh they're not
looking at the data or they're
uninformed and so i think you know it's
pretty pretty remarkable when you when
you kind of dig into it all right and
now the last one we have is you line up
bitcoin and eth mean transfer volume per
one dollar in fees uh what is this
showing us
yeah so this is kind of what i was
referring to a little bit earlier um you
know there's a lot of especially on
crypto twitter or people that are coming
into the space um they like to pit
bitcoin and eat against each other and i
think i think it's really just missing
the point in that they're two entirely
separate things um by far bitcoin is a
global monetary asset it's a political
it's a non-sovereign digital barrier
asset that no one can manipulate that no
one can change um it's meant to do two
things
extremely well better than anything
before and that's store and transfer
value
across the internet in a digital native
way
where ethereum or you know other crypto
currencies as they're called
are you know smart contract platforms or
you can build daps or d5 protocols and
all these sorts of other things um
it's not competing with bitcoin and i
think the framing in general um by most
people especially in the crypto space
you log on to coinbase one and two
bitcoin and each and people say what's
better what should i own um you know is
east gonna flip in bitcoin without
really understanding that the the two
markets that they're competing for are
completely different
um and you know despite maybe them
competing for inflows because people
download the coinbase app they're really
just not competing so what this is
showing is
essentially that you know i just in the
previous chart we showed uh bitcoin's
transfer volume per one dollars in fees
and
basically that settlement efficiency
staying constant for the last decade
with some volatility and this chart is
showing bitcoin versus eth in that
regard and so as ethereum scales as
blockchains in general scale um with
ethereum doing nfts d5 dapps icos
whatever the next thing that ethereum or
these smart contract platforms can do
it's in terms of it as a settlement
network
a value settlement network it's it's far
inferior compared to bitcoin so for
every for every uh one dollar fee is
ethereum the base layer transfers two
hundred twelve dollars a value with
bitcoin at sixty seven thousand dollars
of value and so uh i just think the
framing is wrong in general i get a lot
of questions i get a lot of dm's every
day what do you think about ethereum
what do you think about solana what do
you think about xyz uh and i think just
in general the total adjustable market
for for a political non-sovereign money
uh in
in the digital age is a few hundred
trillion dollars and
uh the value of a smart contract
platform uh or you know whether it's
centralized decentralized or somewhere
in between and you can have that debate
all day
i think it's
it's just different and i think it's a
lot less but that's just a personal
opinion so i think in general the
framing is wrong and i think this kind
of data is pretty interesting to look at
okay so i got a couple more questions
and we're gonna take some questions from
the audience and my brothers as well uh
first one is 90 of bitcoin has now been
mined we talked about it earlier on the
show uh what's your thought process
there is that an important milestone or
you know it was 89.9 a couple days ago
now it's 90. uh it's a round number it
sounds nice but doesn't really change
anything
yeah i mean i think it's just pretty
remarkable when you think about
especially just in 2021 all of the the
you know announcements and all of the
news of new kind of capital flooding
into the bitcoin mining space i don't
know how many there are i think 20
publicly traded miners in the united
states um and you just you see just
these these companies raising massive
amounts of capital to invest to mine the
last 10 of the bitcoin supply over the
next 100 years and then that supply
issuance is um the the curve is you know
front loaded so you're gonna see five
percent of that or around five percent
of that bitcoin mind in the next uh you
know about four years or so um and so by
2030 i think it's around 99 or very
close to it
but just in terms of how much capital
how much resources and how much energy
is going to be dedicated to mining this
last 10 percent of bitcoin issued
it's pretty remarkable and it and it
makes me uh it makes me fumble and buy
some more bitcoin all right the other
thing is um that we just saw uh while
we've been talking lemonade which is a
publicly traded tech enabled insurance
company uh they've added bitcoin to
their balance sheet uh it's a very small
amount it's around a million dollars or
so
how do you think about public companies
adding bitcoin to their balance sheet
we've seen michael saylor continue to
buy aggressively uh is this just a
continuation of the trend or do you feel
like there's been [ __ ] some shift in
sentiment among uh public executives
yeah i mean i think there's still um you
know michael saylor is far ahead of the
curve and i think if you're if you're
watching this and and are actively
stacking bitcoin you are
ahead of the curve as well um you know
these these companies and these
corporations these institutions they
move really slow have a lot some you
know michael saylor has 75 percent of
the voting rates and microstrategy he
can do what he wants um a lot of these
companies you know like twitter doesn't
even have bitcoin in the balance sheet
and jack was a ceo so what does you know
kind of what does that say in terms of
uh other kind of competing interests and
just the information asymmetry and so i
think you know that trend is going to
continue and it's going to uh pick up
but just in terms of allocating to
bitcoin from a corporate level the
accounting standards still are kind of
unfavorable where if bitcoin draws down
it's a it's a loss on your earnings um
some of these things they will change in
the future but i think that the trend
where you see pensions you see uh
corporate treasures you see insurance
funds just you know just a small
allocation to begin with they're
allocating for years decades into the
future um and i think that's that's just
something we're going to see continue
but it'll take some time all right joe
john what questions you have and then
we'll do audience questions hey dylan uh
i just want to know like just give us
your general thoughts on kind of where
we're headed for the next three six nine
months kind of seeing everything in the
market structure not necessarily price
wise but you're just what you're seeing
kind of on chain and your overall
feeling
yeah so i mean i would really love um
honestly i think just some more
consolidation as as managing as it is
for some that want to see us go
parabolic
i think just from kind of we're seeing
on chain from the derivative side of
things where uh traders keep getting
ahead of themselves i think due for some
for some choppiness i think a lot of the
speculators would be it'd be great if if
they left the market and you know i'm
not not hoping anybody leaves or gets
burned but um i think some some boredom
would do us good uh and i honestly think
the next kind of bullish catalyst is is
you're going to see the fed try to hike
they're going to try to taper their
asset purchases
and just off of you know going off
historical precedent over the last you
know really 20 years anytime the fed has
tried to pull back uh the stimulus pull
back the punch bowl it blows up in their
face and i i don't think this time is
different at all and so i think that's
that's really when you see bitcoin just
explode is when you know the the taper
the
the you know rate heights
just blow up in their face and that's
when bitcoin is is going to get bid
probably similar to march of 2020 when
when everything sells off and then
bitcoin recovers first and then
outperforms everything i would i would
imagine that uh would repeat again and
so that's kind of my sentiment over the
next uh really year or so i mean however
long the timeline takes i think i think
bitcoin is more of a macro asset than
ever and i think that's really bullish
gotcha dylan i've seen some charts
recently about just like the general
market of the s p 500 and bitcoin and
the correlation with that what do you
think around bitcoin being correlated to
other assets or in general to the
overall market structure
yeah i mean that's a great point uh
bitcoin increasingly as it grows in
market cap is is just a function i i
believe of um the liquidity of the kind
of the everything bubble um you know
in in traders terms bitcoin is just a
high beta risk asset and over the short
to medium term time frames i that is
true right in march of 2020 when bitcoin
uh sold off really first it almost front
ran everything selling off it bottomed
before everything else people said
bitcoin the bitcoin experiment failed
it's not recession proof it's not it's
not a hedge it's not a diversification
and when in reality
i actually remember you having a great
post about this it was just a liquidity
crunch the dollar got bit and so i think
i think that's what you're really seeing
is that um in the everything bubble
everything's going to go up and then if
credit contracts everything goes down
and really that the outperformers are
are you know kind of the reaction when
they when they respond to to the bust
and so um i think that that's unchanged
and bitcoin will will draw down if
equities go down 20 and that's a good
thing um because they're going to have
to reinflate everything just with you
know the political incentives and
everything else and so um you know over
the short to medium term volatility or
correlations to other risk assets don't
disprove uh the kind of the bitcoin
thesis that it's the best money the
world has ever seen it just kind of
reinforces how uh overextended how far
gone we are in this kind of fiat credit
everything bubble yeah i i think that uh
what you're specifically referring to is
in march of 2020 uh i literally wrote
the piece and it was like explaining
what liquidity crisis are and i went
back and i looked at the 2008 2009
global financial crisis and i was like
hey look when people get scared when
there's uncertainty when there's uh some
sort of fear in the market uh they end
up selling their assets and they go for
the dollar they want security and so
like we're in a liquidity crisis don't
be uh you know um kind of short-term
thinker understand what's happening uh
prices may go down you know more but
ultimately the liquidity crisis does get
solved especially if the government
steps in and then that day bitcoin fell
50
and i gotta say even though i you know
uh conceptually understood what was
happening uh it still doesn't feel good
right you know you buy after like the
twenty percent down but it goes down
another twenty percent you're like okay
cool like you know i'm a genius that
goes down more like dude what is this
going you know how low is this thing
going and uh is this maybe not a
liquidity crisis but are we watching it
go to zero uh and you know obviously uh
the uh what i call the fear buys ended
up being uh pretty good but uh but it's
crazy you know even when you know that
uh this is how liquidity crisis work
they still don't feel good for you know
anyone uh who's uh living through it
right
yeah exactly i think that's that's why
it's also important to not uh be
overexposed i mean you can i'm i think
we're all extremely bullish on bitcoin
but even having uh you know 2x leverage
on your bitcoin position right where if
you're allocated to bitcoin with 200
percent of your net worth is is pretty
dangerous right because these these
events can occur right bitcoin was on a
saturday night two weeks ago it was down
20
uh right like these things are gonna
happen again whether it's uh natively in
bitcoin with the derivatives market or
the macro uncertainty causes bitcoin to
completely unwind and it kind of
cascades on each other right so um you
know always having that pristine
collateral the bitcoin that you're
stacking um if that event occurs then
you can take advantage of that
increasingly so with you know the
ability to collateralize your stack get
fiat liquidity all these things uh
bitcoins increasing like
financialization it's actually an ad
positive uh but you never want to leave
you know you never want to become a
force sheller in one of these events
it's the worst thing you can do um and
so i think that's just important to say
correct i'm going to take a couple of
questions from the audience real quick
i'll just fire them at you you uh you go
ahead and let me know uh what you think
so first one comes from uh youtube user
luco who says dylan are people selling
for the tax year
i think that's probably something to do
with it um you know bitcoin despite the
recent pullback despite the the kind of
mid-year bear market would be down 30
something percent from the all-time high
i mean it's still it opened the year at
29 000 right so there's still a lot of
gains on the table um and so you're
seeing i think you're seeing that and
equity markets you're seeing that uh in
bitcoin just if you're looking at say
like s p uh the momentum has stalled
there's definitely some profit taking um
and maybe there's some there's some wash
selling right with bitcoin if you buy it
at 60k then you can sell it at 40k and
harvest that capital loss uh and rebuy
rate back uh which you can't do with
legacy so i think that is occurring but
uh just kind of one of the many factors
in the market today okay vincent
mckeever asked do you believe there's
any market manipulation by wales
happening right now
no i think the opposite to be honest i
think when people say market
manipulation they're actually mistaking
it for a free market in the sense that
bitcoin has a has the utxo set there
will only ever be 21 million you can
verify ownership on chains and any
manipulation that is occurring is free
market forces if if someone wants to
with 10 000 bitcoin wants to market sell
on bitnext right now uh they're
completely open to do that and then you
know that's a free market at work
volatility is expressing itself in this
asset class uh through derivatives or
spot uh and and that's just all free
market forces and so uh in a world where
the fed comes and you know saves the day
every time the the stock market falls 20
uh people aren't used to this kind of
wild volatility and and you know no
circuit breakers no uh no intervention
right this is the wild wild west and i
think that's that's the way it should be
so in terms of manipulation though i
think it's uh it's actually quite the
opposite and it's a beautiful thing all
right then we've got lloyd gonzalez ask
any price correlation to days people get
paid have you seen any analysis where
there's either uh heavier buying or any
sort of price fluctuations when people
actually get paid on like the first and
the 15th
uh not that i've seen i think in terms
of if you're looking at just kind of um
recent uh price correlations i think uh
the thing that has merit is if you're
looking at uh kind of session times so i
think over the last month or month or
two and this this may be off but i saw a
pretty good post about bitcoin's
performance during uh united states
market hours during asian market hours
and then kind of at the time in between
and during asian market hours over the
last month or two and we saw this in the
summer as well uh bitcoin has
underperformed pretty pretty good uh and
versus when the us is a is like you know
trading or open even though people are
buying 24 7 right like i'm buying hourly
on strike um but regardless i think um
you know there is some merit to maybe uh
different regions or different uh time
zones uh selling selling off and and
that's just something to see uh you know
play out over over different time spans
it's interesting to look at
awesome all right we've got two people
who asked uh pretty much the same
question so estevan torjik i believe how
you pronounce it and then saleem all uh
they're basically asking about
protracted cycles or do you believe in a
lengthened uh kind of bull market cycle
um and kind of that goes to the question
of like how do you expect maybe the next
90 days you know the new year kind of q1
to play out as well
yeah so i am a believer in the lincoln
cycle thesis if you want to call it that
um i think in the early days um i mean
bitcoin is always just driven by
additional adoption of of you know
people understanding the monetary asset
uh but i think disproportionately the
havings played a huge effect in the
early days just with with you know the
relative size of the new issuance you
know being cut in half whereas now the
inflation rate of bitcoin annualized is
about 1.8 percent uh decreasing that to
you know 0.9 percent in 2024 is is
significant um and in the sense that no
one can control it and stop it from
happening but in just in terms of
relative market impact it's i think it's
smaller than it was in the past and so
um the lengthening cycle thesis i think
has a lot of merit and i think more so
you know there's this kind of underlying
adoption curve if you want to look and
say realize cap or realize price of that
occurring that's great but more so i
think especially in the coming years the
bitcoin adoption will be uh a result of
kind of the macro environment and people
being forced into an alternative
a viable alternative you know with
something that can't be printed
richard stevens asks uh what your
opinion on the stock to flow model is
and i'm assuming that uh the thought
process is uh obviously in november it
seems that there's some sort of
violation um of kind of plan b's opinion
now again i think his view is that the
stock to flow model isn't necessarily
violated but how do you look at stock to
flow uh the accuracy or efficacy of that
and has anything changed there
yeah people you know people always have
strong opinions on stock to flow and i
was always just of the opinion that was
a really cool way to kind of visualize
um absolute scarcity and supply and
elasticity um you know i when the stock
deflo model was released and i believe
the spring of 2019 um i ifomo stacked
very very hard so i'm grateful for plan
b and and it was kind of one of the
things that made the supply and
elasticity and the programmatic scarcity
of bitcoin click for me and i think it
did for a lot of people as well and so
you know is it invalid or valid or is it
you know statistically uh you know
significant or all these things that you
can kind of look at i mean i don't know
and i to be honest i i don't really care
i think you know plan b is has opened a
lot of people's eyes to bitcoin and kind
of uh this reality of the absolute
scarcity of it um and so you know
whether whether the model is valid or
not or his various you know stock to
flow cross-asset model all these
different things
i think it's just it's just uh you know
all models are are
invalid some are useful right so none of
this is is you know true per se it's
just uh you know it's just a way to kind
of think of things in different ways and
so
um i i don't really know i just i think
it's a cool way to kind of visualize it
all right and then how do you think
about lost coins um or satoshi's coins
earlier we were talking about uh chain
analysis has an estimation that 3.7
million bitcoin are lost uh there's
estimations that satoshi has you know
800 000 to a million bitcoin um if that
is true and let's just use round numbers
they're somewhere between uh kind of
four and a half to
five million bitcoin that are lost or
held by satoshi that would be a big
percentage of the total 21 million
bitcoin supply like do you have any idea
in terms of how accurate those numbers
are and also do you have any thoughts in
how that impacts uh kind of future price
or supply demand economics
yeah i think i mean for anybody that
hasn't kind of dug through the bitcoin
talk forms and all that there's some
pretty uh early og discussions about all
this and it's kind of fascinating to dig
through it all satoshi actually was
quoted saying lost coins are a donation
to everybody they make their coins more
more valuable and so you know satoshi's
coins are presumably satoshi's coins you
know a million of them or something
around there having never been moved um
it's it's you know kind of an altruistic
donation to everybody and so you know
it's kind of one of the things about
bitcoin that as you really fall down the
rabbit hole you kind of come to
understand is that if i acquire this
thing um whether it's through mining or
through you know if you acquire bitcoin
in any sort of way it's proof of work
you're exchanging some sort of valuable
uh good or service and someone else is
paying you with bitcoin and if you never
sell that if you never put it back on
the market well it's it's increasing
everyone else's relative purchasing
power it's it's
basically increasing everyone else's
productivity um so it's a pretty
interesting kind of thought experiment
in the sense that you know say if
michael sailor and every cells bitcoin
well you know everyone else in a way
almost got a little bit richer uh and so
i think i don't know i don't know how
many coins satoshi has i don't know how
many are lost i think the two to three
to four million ballpark is is pretty
accurate
but over time i think you know more
bitcoin will be lost and so uh you know
your purchasing power will will increase
as a result and so you know it's a
pretty cool thing
all right and then the last question i
have is obviously we've seen the el
salvador bitcoin back bond uh and that
seems to be a pretty interesting uh way
for nation states to get more exposure
to bitcoin uh but also to give certain
types of investors who couldn't buy
bitcoin directly some exposure as well
uh what's the implications of that or
the impact on the market and do you
think that we'll see more of that
happening uh at kind of the municipal or
nation state level uh you know as we
kind of continue here
yeah i think it's it's really it's a
really interesting model especially for
for countries that can't print their own
currency right el salvador was was that
first nation that uh is dollarized that
doesn't have a central bank that doesn't
have their own currency and so it's like
all right i'll just plug into this open
monetary network and build around it um
and so you know i kind of suspect other
nations that are in a similar position
will do the same and in terms of the
bitcoin backed bonds i mean uh the
entire
kind of sovereign debt bubble right
there's 100 200 i think you know i would
say around 400 trillion dollars of
assets uh you know really more so debt
that are priced just you know basically
completely backwards it's you know real
yields are negative everywhere so all of
these contracts are guaranteed to lose
money if fiat is debasing and and what
we know about fiat is it has to do base
and so
you know a bitcoin back bond and giving
kind of these capital allocators an
alternative that you know potentially
with a lot of upside is very very
interesting uh and you know i don't know
if if the bond has officially been
subscribed to or not but uh it'll be
interesting to see how it trades and i
think uh with with it kind of being on
the liquid network we'll see this oh you
know these bitcoin back bonds trade on
say a bitfenix or an ftx just like you
know other kind of crypto assets would
so i think that's a pretty interesting
kind of development as well
got it um jojo you guys got anything
else this is super valuable dylan so
thank you so much for taking the time to
uh to come on dylan how do you think
about drawbacks like do you think that
we're going to see another you know 80
drawback or something like that when we
whether we hit that top of the cycle yet
or not but do you think when it does
come that we'll see that
yeah i mean i i think in terms of an 80
draw drawdown what you really need is a
blow off top and and we got that to an
extent but not really um i think the sub
this summer almost was a bear market in
itself and so
for for an 80 drawdown what you'd really
need is is some
mega blow off top with you know and with
bitcoin at a trillion dollar asset class
or
890 so billion uh i think i think it's a
lot harder to do compared to when
bitcoin was a 10 million dollar or a
billion dollar asset class and so uh for
an eighty percent three eighty percent
drawdown three year bear market uh i
think i don't know that's not my base
case at all i think we're kind of you
know more so of the say like the rounded
tops and round the rounded bottoms that
we've seen in 2021 um i wouldn't be
surprised at all to see that continue
and actually that's somewhat of my base
case bitcoin just kind of chugs along
over the next
you know
one year two years however many years it
takes until until you know there is no
more cycles and bitcoin uh you know kind
of melts away all the fiat but i think
we're still a little bit away from that
and so you know the the 40 50 60
drawdowns um but not so much a three
year cycle or three year protracted bear
i think that's more so kind of my base
case but you know i've been wrong in the
past so we'll see i guess
gotcha quick follower update he's at
97.1
000 followers from closing in on 100k
just absolutely blowing by people let's
go
what uh you hit it on christmas day
that's legendary what he's gonna hit
he's gonna hit 100 in the next two three
days probably but uh can we still get to
150 you think
that's that's that's tough bob it
depends on
i wouldn't count it out it depends what
the price does yeah i don't know man
jump in
i think we got a shot all right i lost
my i lost my check mark for wrong thing
for what
for wrong think on twitter
jack left
wait what happened
uh
i don't know wait you lost your blue
check mark
yeah
the day jack left
no the day jack left
yeah
oh get the hell out of here hey twitter
folks i know you're watching listen give
it back
that's what we need give it back to him
why did you guys take that from him that
wasn't yours to take that was his he
earned that was there any explanation or
no
i know they just said i wasn't notable
anymore
[Laughter]
they said bitcoin's price fell too much
so that's like never mind he said
all you bitcoiners shut the hell up jack
ain't here no more
that's all all right man listen thank
you so much for doing this i dropped uh
your uh uh twitter uh link into the chat
make sure you guys go follow him uh
obviously they're gonna take his blue
check mark the best way to get revenge
is to let's get into 150 000 followers
by the end of the year uh but i
appreciate all the hard work you're
doing i think people are learning a lot
so uh for those that don't know dylan is
going to be coming on every tuesday now
moving forward so uh
[Music]
that's how we welcome people he's part
of the union he's definitely not part of
the union he is dylan do you want to
know the fastest way to get uninvited to
the show is join the union just so we're
all clear here that's not true dylan
that's amanda i thought it already
joined you already and we totally we uh
we pay out in bitcoin we haven't sent
you yours yet but
now the union is paying out people i
thought the union is supposed to collect
this it's kind of like a ponzi scheme we
collect money
all right we gotta go i appreciate you
coming on man we'll do it again next
week
see you guys later buddy